many of us want to become entrepreneurs
starting your own business is one of the
biggest dreams of our times but how do
you get to be an entrepreneur most of
the advice focuses on the practicalities
writing a business plan raising money
finding staff marketing and pl will go
down a different route in our eyes at
the heart of successful entrepreneurship
lie something oddly more abstract an
accurate insight into the causes of
human unhappiness to be an entrepreneur
means essentially to become an expert in
the things that make life difficult for
people that's because every properly
ambitious business is in some way trying
to fix things for other people and the
bigger and more original what you're
trying to fix happens to be the more
successful your business can be because
consumer society is now well developed
it may be easy to think that all the big
problems out there already have
thousands of fixes anyway think of all
those car companies or pizza outlets or
news websites we surely have enough of
everything what could we possibly add to
what's already out there but to get a
sense of the vast opportunities that
still remain in capitalism all you need
to do is ask yourself where and in what
areas you're unhappy in the course of an
average day every unhappiness is really
a new business waiting to be born your
frustrations are a nearly inexhaustible
source of raw materials out of which the
businesses of the future can be built so
while there may already be plenty of
breakfast cereals and t-shirts and
cellphones and cab rides for sale
there's so much more that frustrates and
depresses us think of how difficult it
is to get on with one's partner educate
children cope with anxiety discover what
you want to do with your life find a
nice place to live calm down in the
evening
one could go on and on our griefs and
irritations are endless thankfully for
the budding entrepreneurs the biggest
first step to take towards
entrepreneurship is therefore to learn
to study your own unhappiness and what
might possibly heal it for you and
others when profits decline in
businesses it's really the result of too
many people throwing themselves at
trying to fix the same area because they
can't think of anything more innovative
to do rather than start a new airline
mobile phone company or supermarket
chain and by contrast healthy profits
are a reward for understanding and
mastering an area of human distress
ahead of anyone else
of course ideas aren't enough on their
own you need to take care of
practicalities and money but they won't
help you if your original psychological
insight into human unhappiness isn't
sound and by the same token if your
insight into what makes people unhappy
is razor sharp and your solutions bold
then however difficult the journey your
business will stand a high chance of
making money and benefit in humanity too
you
you